you don't want to drop
oh my gosh and that's the call to the
butterball turkey hotline so let's talk
about
cooking the cooking the turkey the main
attraction butterball expert samantha
wolf is joining us right now with some
good advice good morning samantha we're
so glad you're with us um telling turkey
jokes this morning so i don't want to
drop that theme yet here i've got one
for you
why was mom's turkey
seasoning a little flat last year
it was too salty she ran out of time
oh
okay
okay all right there we go we got the
bad jokes out of the way all right so
now let's get to your expertise and uh
tell us about the uh the talk the turkey
talk taste kitchen what what's that
about this year with butterball
sure well we're celebrating our 40th
season at the butterball turkey talk
line and we started a turkey chocolate
cake kitchen um in our corporate office
so we're testing trends techniques
we test turkeys every year as a team but
this is new this year because we're
featuring it on tic-tac
so you can check out butterball's
tic-tac and you can see different trends
recipes techniques and we're just all
about helping that host this year oh i'm
sure you're getting a lot more eyeballs
on tick-tock
than uh
than ever before right because that's
why everybody's learning things
with a really short attention span so
you can learn how to do a turkey in just
30 seconds that's awesome
all right so we're all still learning
about turkeys
not everybody's an expert maybe this is
someone's first thanksgiving
please tell us how to avoid some of the
really common mistakes that people make
when they're doing a turkey in the oven
so newer season hosts were here to help
i would say the biggest thing is having
a thermometer on hand that's really the
only way to test for doneness
so our recommendation is always open pan
roast your turkey and we're looking for
three temperatures in the thigh we want
it to reach 180 degrees in the breast
170 and if you're stuffing your turkey
we recommend that reaching 165 degrees
for food safety okay so always the
thermometer is it too late to thaw your
turkey this morning samantha
it depends when you're cooking it today
um hopefully most people have their sod
turkeys but if they have some time we
can run them through some cold water
baths to help continue that thaw until
they're ready to cook it okay
and last question what are some really
good ideas for leftovers we've been
talking about that this morning
yes so definitely visit us on tiktok
because we have this turkey waffle
sandwich i'm using leftover stuffing
turkey and the stuffing is actually the
crust and you make it in a waffle maker
and it's crunchy
chewy really good
so that's a great one we have tons of
recipes on butterball.com
for leftovers or even if you're planning
on friendsgiving maybe later on this
weekend so you could check those out as
well
a turkey waffle sandwich made with
stuffing
oh wow all right
you got our attention samantha thank you
so much we appreciate it hopefully we'll
talk to you again through the morning
hours i'm sure we'll have some other
questions too but wow tick-tock it's all
about tick-tock happy thanksgiving
samantha yeah every thanksgiving